who is Elon Musk going to vote for for
president
well in a lot of Elections it's not so
much who you vote for is who you vote
against see yourself voting for
President Biden if if it's it's a Biden
Trump election for
example I think I would not vote for
Biden you'd vote for Trump I'm not
saying I'd vote for Trump but I
mean this is this is definitely a
difficult Choice here you know would you
would you vote for Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley by the way wants uh all social
media
um names to be exposed as you know no I
think that's outrageous yeah no I'm not
going to vote for some Pro censorship
candidate oh it's going to be a
difficult Choice i' uh guess I don't
know I'm not going to vote for Biden not
going to vote for Nikki Haley he says so
what do we conclude from this
it means that look maybe he'll just vote
for Trump and he's just trying to be Cy
about it I think Elon is expressing
something deeper here which is that he
opposes the old
consensus and Nikki Haley fairly or
unfairly has become a representative of
the old consensus she just got the big
endorsement of the coke Network the coke
Network used to be the force in
Republican politics it's still a major
Force but since 2016 things have changed
a little bit the the alternately
neoconservative and
libertarian uh talking points that once
drove the Republican Party they've
fallen out of
favor the the shades of conservatism of
the Bush years or even alternately the
um Paul Ryan you know fiscal Hawk just
cut spending years they're kind of
over likewise Joe Biden certainly
represents the old consensus because he
was around at the founding of the
country and I think he signed the
Declaration of Independence Elon Musk is
saying no
anyone who
represents the policies of 20 years ago
or in Biden's case you know 300 years
ago I'm not voting for that person we
need someone to shake things up and I
think a lot of people feel that way
right now go to stpaul center.com I
recently had my friend Dr Scott Han on
the show he is the founder of the St
Paul Center which is one of the fastest
growing Catholic organizations in the
world I uh love Scott I think that he is
one of if not the leading Catholic
Theologian around today so important to
so many people and they are spreading
the good news and spreading biblical
literacy the St Paul Center's mission is
to give you the tools that you need to
know to love scripture better to become
more confident in your faith to most
importantly grow closer to Christ
himself in order to achieve this the St
Paul Center founded a new digital
learning platform called meas academyus
Academy features over 20 video courses
book studies and original series giving
you the ability to learn from
world-class theologians like Dr Han and
Dr John bergsma as if you were right
there with them in the classroom start
learning more about church history how
to interpret the Bible the basics of
Christian prayer and more St Paul Center
stpaul
center.com Mi i a l you can begin
exploring Aus Academy for free for the
first two weeks imagine what would be
possible if we could all fortify
ourselves with a deeper understanding of
scripture and Faith don't miss the
opportunity stpaul
center.com hey Michael hope you're doing
well and I hope you had a happy
Thanksgiving my question is more on can
you give me advice on something I have
been with my fiance for about 3 years
and we're due to be married in June I am
am currently looking into becoming a
Catholic and there's a parish near me
that does do the rcia all year round and
I am looking into that but he just
basically is stagnant in his
relationship with God which is not
something that I want he doesn't try to
move forward in virtue or reading the
Bible or anything like that and I feel
like that's that's a very important part
of any relationship is to center it
around God and I don't really know what
to do there are some other things that
have to do with finance and everything
like that that he goes backwards on
instead of moving forward and trying to
get better it it's like he's going
backwards
and um I I he says that if I become
Catholic he'll become Catholic but he's
doing it mostly just so that we can be
together and to please me I think and
that that's not what I want and so any
advice will be helpful thank you you
know the advice that you want you you're
not asking me for the advice that you
think you're asking me
for you don't want to marry this guy you
you're making that quite clear you're
saying yeah this guy he's a complete
loser he's a loaf he's he he's not
virtuous at all he's a coward he's a
cuck he's a weakling he yeah he's
financially irresponsible he's just he's
just a total loser so what do you think
I should do
Michael I don't know whether he's a
loser or not all I know is what you just
told me but what I do know is that you
don't want to marry this guy and and
you're asking me for permission to break
up with him well if you want to break up
with them break up with them you don't
need my permission you don't need
anybody else's permission for that
you're not married yet so just break up
with them if you don't want to break up
with him then I think
what you have to identify is that your
issue here is not just exactly how he's
approaching religion look I was an
atheist for 10 years people can take
circuitous Roots back home to the church
and and to the a right relationship with
God but everything you're complaining
about with regard to your boyfriend
right now gets to a deeper issue which I
guess ultimately is religious because it
comes down to Genesis 3 and that's
basically that your your boyfriend
doesn't want to take a leadership role
in in the relationship
he just wants to be a a loaf and a a
follower and uh just do whatever you do
and uh not have to grow up and act like
a man so that's the problem and and if
you do want to fix the relationship and
end up getting married to him you you
got to just tell them to act like a man
and shape up and be a leader and or or
else you know go find someone else
because you're going to dump that zero
and get yourself a hero girl you know
like that that's really what what you're
saying here but from the way you're
talking about you're not saying look I
love him we're he's he's just so such a
wonderful man and he tries his best but
no you're saying this guy's just a total
loser and I don't really like him am I
allowed to break up with him please
Michael yeah sure okay fine and the
reason probably that you feel that way
about him is because because of that
failure of leadership women don't want
some guy who's going to be a little wimp
or a s no no woman wants that so if you
want to keep him around I would just get
right to the heart of the matter look
sweet little Alisa has had to do this to
me not not uh to quite the extreme that
you're describing here with your
boyfriend but but you know a m much
shallower way but still meaningful on
Friday nights when we're trying to
figure out what to eat I don't know when
you know whenever we want to go out to
night Alisa says Mac what do you want to
have for dinner and I say I don't know
what do you want to have for dinner I
don't know we could do Italian yeah I we
could do Indian yeah we could do I don't
know we could get sushi yeah what do you
want I don't know what do you want what
do you want I don't know what do you
want ma you're the man make a decision
head of household Genesis chapter 3 man
up that's that's the answer I say oh
sorry girl you know what you're right
we're getting Sushi you're right I got
to act like a man so I would tell him
that or just dump him if you really
don't like him at all man what a great
clip that was now hey whoa ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time